aber auch in nordrhein westfalen und
hessen überall unsere reporter unterwegs
wie gehen zuerst auf den brocken dort
haben wir gestern hans harwig gesehen
wie er sich wirklich durch den sturm
gekämpft hat er konnte sich trotz der
mann starker statue kaum auf den beinen
halten dort oben ist dann etwas weiter
runter gefahren und wir haben
beeindruckende bilder von dir gestern
bekommen haben ist wie die bäume
wirklich während wir mit ihr gesprochen
haben wie streichhölzer umgefallen sind
zeigt uns einmal deine allererste sturm
bilanz dort
also das ist wirklich ein moment wie
reporter begeben uns ja gerne an orte um
eben für unsere zuschauer davon zu
berichten wo was passiert das heißt wir
sind relativ hart gesotten sage ich mal
so aber wenn hinter einem während einer
schalte wirklich riesige bäume umstürzen
und man schutzlos da einfach steht das
geht durch mark und bein und ich glaube
dann kann man sich auch diese wucht
vorstellen dass es eben keine lappalie
ist wenn bäume umstürzen wir sind jetzt
hier genau am fuße des brocken in
schierke im harz hier ist es eine
ferienhaussiedlung das sogenannte finn
hütten die in der ddr gebaut worden die
extrem beliebt waren bei urlaubern hier
konnte man also mit mehreren familien in
der natur in der nähe der natur direkt
am nationalpark ferien machen und wir
sehen hier das gestern auch der sturm
diese fichten umgehauen hat und direkt
auf diese hütten drauf geworfen hat und
wir können man näher rangehen auch hier
ist dieser diese riesige fichte
umgebrochen und man sieht hier eben
jetzt auch zum glück war gestern niemand
hier in diesen hütten die sind
offensichtlich nicht mehr in betrieb
glücklicherweise aber wenn wir näher ran
gehen dann können wir eben auch erkennen
dass was ich gestern auch schon gesagt
habe die ursachen für diesen windwurf
wie es heißt das sind eben die extrem
trockenen jahre gewesen die extrem
dünnen sommer in den letzten jahren und
daneben der borkenkäfer man kann hier
glaube ich ganz gut diese löcher
erkennen die die käfer hier ein gebohrt
haben und die bäume umgebracht haben das
sind also nur noch tot in grippe die
hier stehen und wenn dann eben der wind
kommt dann ist es für ihn ein leichtes
diese riesigen holz monster eben
umzuwerfen und eben hier so eine ganze
ferienhaussiedlung zu zerstören zum
glück war niemand zum glück sind es eben
nur sachschäden aber die sind heftig und
ich habe eben gestern selber erlebt wie
wahnsinnig imposant das ist wenn solche
bäume hier zersplittern geben uns mal
einen ausblick kann es auf das was die
menschen dort im harz jetzt für den
kommenden tag erwarten denn es ist ja
leider keine entspannung angesagt
besonders für den abend hinein jetzt
sehen wir dich da wir nicht die haare
weg oder fast schon der ganze mensch mit
weg so wie gestern das erwarten die
menschen dort im harz
es ist die sprichwörtliche ruhe vor dem
sturm natürlich die feuerwehren die hier
vor allem freiwillig sind sind eben in
alarmbereitschaft das wochenende steht
vor der tür so denn die arbeitgeber das
erlauben werden die wachen pö a pö jetzt
besetzt schon dauerhaft ansonsten sind
das ja immer nah am ketten und dann
kommen die leute praktisch von
arbeitsplätzen zu den einsatzorten das
wird jetzt langsam aufgestockt die
rettungskräfte bereiten sich vor auf das
schlimmste wir haben es ja gestern schon
gesehen dass große drops von
feuerwehrleuten freiwilligen
feuerwehrleuten mit kettensägen
rettungswege wieder frei schneiden das
ist eben dann die hauptarbeit wenn nicht
menschen in gefahr sind oder verletzt
sind logischerweise geht das natürlich
fordert wird runter priorisiert und
purple werden dann auch schienenwege
oder eben andere gefahren stellen
gesichert da kommt dann teilweise das
thw auch zum einsatz wenn eben die
feuerwehr nicht gefragt ist so teilen
die retter sich dann praktisch auf dann
kann es war uns wichtig ist eben auch
noch mal die
danke so die nationalparkverwaltung sagt
ebenfalls plant gut dann ja erstmal wir
sehen uns im laufe des tages immer
wieder danke die johannes für diese
eindrücke aus dem harz wg nach hamburg
von wo wir diese beeindruckende bilder
von der elbfähre gesehen haben die ja
opfer einer riesigen welle dort auf der
elbe geworden ist gestern das bilder aus
hamburg und dann natürlich auch in der
stadt die typische geschichte baum auf
autobauer auf hauses hat gestern
hunderte getroffen peter du hast eine
solche geschichte am heutigen tag
richtigkeit wir sind hier im osten von
hamburg in einer kleinbürgerlichen
siedlung bei familie putz ab und denen
ist gestern morgen eine große tanne aus
ihrem garten aufs haus gefallen wir
können uns das hier anschauen man sieht
mit welcher enormen naturgewalt dieser
massive baumängel gestern morgen einfach
von dem starken wind entwurzelt wurde
der baum ist dann eben hier auf das dach
gefallen wir sehen dort oben dort ist
ein loch in das dach gerissen worden
also auch ein enormer schaden und das
wohl notdürftig mit einer plane
abgedeckt aber natürlich muss das jetzt
schnell verbessert werden und da kommen
natürlich auch kosten auf die
familienkutsche zu wir haben uns gesagt
die waren gestern morgen hier als der
haut baum ihn aufs dach gefallen ist und
sie hätten sogar vorher sich auch noch
gedanken gemacht dass das ja durchaus
passieren könnte mit diesem großen baum
im garten ja und dann wurden sie
tatsächlich vom unwetter schlecht
überrascht unglücklich überrascht wir
können uns das hier auch anschauen da
wurden auch dachziegel durch den garten
gerissen die liegen ja überall verteilt
man sieht zerbrochen also wenn man sich
davor stellt mit was für einer gewalt
mit was für einem meiner kraft der wind
diese dachziegel hier durch diese durch
dieses viertel schießt ist gut
auszumalen wie gefährlich das werden
kann aber die feuerwehr war eben gestern
schnell hier und hat den baum erst mal
vom dach geholt der nicht jetzt hier
noch und muss jetzt natürlich schnell
beseitigt werden ein geübter ist dort
nichts passiert ist wenn man diese
bilder sieht peter wirke vielen dank
aber schon direkt weiter zu markus
hibbeler nach wilhelmshaven denn auch
dort mussten leute vor dem sturm fliehen
patricia ich befinde mich gerade in
dangast das ist unweit von wilms hafen
auf der anderen seite des jadebusens und
hinter mir sieht man den campingplatz
der ja bis vor einiger zeit hier noch
voll war mit camper an die camper haben
hier fluchtartig den platz verlassen
weil der normalerweise bei jeder
sturmflut hier komplett unter wasser
steht also das wasser reicht dann
normalerweise wenn hochwasser ist und
genau darauf stellen die menschen sich
hier ja auch ein bis hier an den deich
wo ich gerade stehe man hat hier den
deich erhöht die ganzen letzten
jahrzehnte und wir haben es ja gerade
schon gehört wir haben warnstufe violett
das heißt wir bekommen wahrscheinlich
die schwerste sturmflut seit jahrzehnten
am nachmittag und auch in der kommenden
nacht und entsprechend stellen die leute
sich hier auch darauf ein der strand
kiosk hinter mir der befindet sich so
hinter mir schräg rechts der hat auch
schon dicht gemacht das heißt man sieht
hier kaum ein mensch wir wollen nachher
auch noch mit einer familie sprechen die
die strandbar hier verwaltet sozusagen
die verbarrikadieren jetzt auch ihr
gebäude das ist quasi auch ihr
lebenstraum denen die hier haben heißt
die leute haben hier schon sehr sehr
große angst und tiefsten abwirft schon
die schatten insofern voraus dass es
hierfür einer stunde schon richtig
gegossen hat wind mäßig ist es gerade
200 ruhig aber die menschen stellen will
sich auch auf das schlimmste ein gerade
an der küste danke markus hibbeler dort
nach wilhelmshaven oder dort wo du
stehst du hast es gerade gesagt dort
herrscht alarmstufe violett also dort
wird eine heftige du sagst die heftigste
sturmflut wohl seit jahrzehnten erwartet
in den nächsten stunden in den nächsten
anderthalb tagen danke für deine
eindrücke dort vom deich wir gehen
weiter zu unserem wetterexperten zu
karsten brandt und wollte das einmal
ganz genau einschätzen was da auf uns
zurollt wir sehen es auf den karten und
das sieht jetzt auf den karten
tatsächlich sehr bedrohlich aus was
bedeutet schon guten tag carsten violett
umlauft dieser wahn karte auf dieser
orkan waren karte das ist so die höchste
warnstufe die wir haben und es ist so
wir können im augenblick das
tiefdruckgebiet schon in aktion sehen
damit meine ich jetzt nicht den regen
über deutschland sondern wir sehen schon
was es in england anrichtet und da würde
ich gleich noch mal darauf eingehen also
da haben wir schon extreme auswirkungen
auch extrem hohen hohe
windgeschwindigkeiten und wir haben ein
phänomen was sich stinken jet nennt das
ist nur ein kleiner bereich hinter der
ersten wetterfront die durchzieht die im
bereich von 300 kilometer länge bis etwa
30 kilometer breite wo die
windgeschwindigkeiten extrem hoch gehen
und da im bereich von 140 150 160
stundenkilometer selbst für meteorologen
eigentlich nicht alltäglich
unvorstellbar also dass damit rechnet
man aktuell in england und das ist auch
eine gefahr für heute abend für heute
späten nachmittag abend für die
nordseeküste aber da geht mir gleich
darauf ein also erstmal geht es los 14
15 uhr von westen her wilhelmshaven aber
auch ostfriesland insgesamt friesischen
inseln da geht der wind dann plötzlich
sehr sehr schnell stark los es geht dann
auch sehr schnell in den in den lokalen
bereich hinein es ist die kaltfront die
da rein kommt die wird auch nrw
betreffen also ins ruhrgebiet runter
auch da kurzzeitig für ein paar stunden
110 bis 120 stundenkilometern bevor hier
zu viel zahlen sagt dieser war da geht
es nicht nur um so kleine stöckchen hier
was dann so gerne mal runter fällt
sondern was gestern wir reden hier über
über solche brummer die dann da
unterkommen können also das ist höchste
höchste gefahr höchste alarmstufe
da kommen also wirklich holzstücke erste
bäume runter in sehr kurzer zeit und
hinter dieser kaltfront wird das wetter
sich etwas beruhigen in der mitte
deutschlands also in nrw wird kurzzeitig
ruhiger aber an der nordseeküste gibt es
dann erst so richtig los dann befürchten
wir genau diesen ja diesen sting jet
über der nordsee über der elbe über
schleswig holstein hamburg dann rüber
bis zur ostsee und da können dann
unfassbare windgeschwindigkeiten
aufdrehen bis zu 140 oder 150
stundenkilometer und damit auch eine
extreme sturm war gefragt wie gesagt
läuft auf eingehen
dass also die hotspots für den komme für
die kommenden stunden wie lange wird uns
das ganze denn carsten begleiten ist
denn dann irgendwie zum wochenende hin
langsame entwarnung in sicht ja also
dass das wird mit sicherheit der
schlimmste strom jetzt sein das kann
nicht glaube ich sagen also der zweite
das ist auch fast traditionell schon so
dass das zweite sturmtief bei diesen
strom marathon meist das schlimmste ist
und also damit kann ich schon sagen wird
morgen übermorgen erwin zwar immer noch
zum teil stark sein wir haben morgen den
mittelgebirgen morgen nachmittag aber
auch am am sonntag und auch am montag
immer noch mal sturm aber das ist bei
weitem nicht mehr so dramatisch wie was
heute nachmittag heute abend passiert
und weil ich noch ein satz zur
nordseeküste wir haben ein nach den
berechnungen jetzt eine höhe von
88 meter 20 88 ihrem boot der pegel da
steht das ist nur einen meter bis 1
meter 50 unter unter der deichkrone also
ich denke die behörden wissen deswegen
hat man auch hier wert gegeben die
behörden sind glaube ich alarmiert ich
würde heute nacht mann und maus an die
deiche schicken und gucken dass da
nichts das damit dass wir kein
durchbruch erleben das ist eine sehr
sehr gefährliche situation besonders für
schleswig holstein soll das für den 11
also runter cuxhaven bis bis nach
hamburg sehr vorsichtig sein 60 jahre
nach diesem ereignis was wir erlebt
haben also ich würde die behörden
wirklich dass sie da aufpassen dass wir
keinen durchbruch erleben es ist
gefährlich also mir sehr gefällt wir
können aber ganz kurz darauf eingehen da
kann ich mich gar nicht daran erinnern
dass diese deiche nicht gehalten haben
die ja normalerweise auch so weiter weg
sind man steht auf dem deich und sucht
meistens die nordsee das heißt sie gehen
davon aus dass möglicherweise evakuiert
werden muss hinter den deichen heute
dass das sein kann dass das eine notlage
sein kann in schleswig-holstein
niedersachsen
also wir hoffen dass natürlich nicht und
wer ich gehe auch davon aus dass die
deiche halten also ich bin da eigentlich
ziemlich optimistisch aber das ist ja
genau das gefährliche dass man sagt wir
gehen davon aus dass alles gut geht und
dann kommt es doch zu problemen also wie
gesagt das wasser nach den prognosen des
des bshd die diese vorhersagen erstellen
ligue 1 meter ein meter fünfzig unter
der deichkrone also da ist noch luft
aber man man sollte einfach vorsichtig
sein wie gesagt das ist eine extreme
sturm lage seit jahrzehnten haben wir so
etwas nicht gehabt und man diese
ungewissheit sollte man raus nehmen
deswegen würde ich sagen wirklich da ich
wach heute nacht aufpassen es wurden
über jahrzehnte die gleiche immer wieder
erhöht die sind sehr gut in schuss die
sind sehr gut in schuss gehalten in
deutschland kann man sich eigentlich
darauf verlassen trotzdem auf nummer
sicher gehen trotzdem kann was passieren
und deswegen sollten wir dafür gibt es
diese tat in der nacht dass wir alle
besser schlafen dass das wieder
gesichert sind danke karsten brandt
bildwerte für die einschätzung und die
eindringliche warnung auch hier gerne
bei bild live auch an alle die